So all the memory protection
stuff that we have talked about,
how can we use that to prevent
malicious code execution on the stack?
Okay, remember, you're going to alter
the return address, then you're going
to insert some instructions where
you're going to transfer control and
things like that.
So one of the things
we're going to do is,
what if we have a non-executable stack?
We actually talked about that's one of
the protections for code injection,
because you have to inject your code
when you overwrite the return address to
point to this code.
And then you execute that code,
that's how a successful exploit works.
So now think what we can do if we
made the stack non-executable, right?
So this is important,
non-executable stack,
which means you could go right into it,
you can store some instructions into it.
So in some sense you're able to inject
the instructions onto the stack,
but you will not be able
to to execute those, okay?
Because remember we're talking
with address consolation and
space level entries, and
read write execute permissions in each
of those pages that you can access
through the space level entries.
Well, if we say it's non-executable,
non-executable is you can only read or
write [INAUDIBLE] location when you want
to fetch an instruction off the stack.
This is your injection code
that we are talking about.
You can't execute off of that, so
setting the permission to non-execute
actually is going to prevent malicious
code to inject code on the stack,
and use the buffer overflows
to transfer control to it, and
successfully exploit
a program by doing that.
A simple thing we can do is,
you can't execute off the stack, so
your injection code
can't be on the stack.
So, this sort of protection,
actually more than operating systems,
make the stack non-executable.
So, the way you understand that is,
this protection comes because
that portion of the address
space where the stack lives.
The page table entries that are used to
translate addresses from the range
of addresses with the stack is,
those page table entries have
execution permission turned off.
So you can't execute off
the stack because it's going to
require that you fetch an instruction
from a certain memory location where
the execute permission is not there.
So memory isolation protection,
that discussion we've been having,
gives us a simple way to protect
our execution on the stack
by making the stack non-executable.
And that avoids or
prevents this malicious code to
use a buffer of overflows and
use code injection on this stack.